la comisión europea lo que ha presentado
hoy es una clasificación para distinguir
qué tipo de energías son sostenibles y
cuáles no esto sirve para ayudar a los
inversores para decidir dónde invertir
en qué proyectos dedicados a la
transición ecológica la unión europea
está decidida a apostar para que en 2050
ya sea la primera región climáticamente
neutra pero para ello necesita la
inversión privada para poder llegar a
esta transición ecológica y por lo tanto
poder apostar por energías renovables la
unión europea aún depende mucho del
carbón algo que quiere reducir sobre
todo en países como polonia hungría
eslovaquia pero también alemania así que
la comisión europea lo que espera es que
con esta clasificación se pueda dar algo
de claridad para la transición ecológica